Government programs benefit the poor at the
expense of the rich. Those are the terms on
which many public welfare programs are
sold. But is that really the case? The
economist Milton Friedman doesn’t think
so and called this the Robin Hood myth.
Friedman argued that instead of taking
from the rich to help the poor, most
welfare programs benefit the middle-class
at the expense of the very poor and the
very rich. This happens because of a
simple rule, known as Director‘s law.
In a democratic system, laws are passed by 51
percent of the people voting one way against
49 percent of the people voting another.
You might think the bottom 51 percent will
pass laws at the expense of the top 49
percent, but that is rarely the case.
Directors law implies that the bottom 51
percent tend to not only be less fortunate,
but also less likely to have the ability to
organize themselves and be politically successful.
The top 51 percent are able to use their
power to control politics. But they are,
by definition, also most comfortable
with how things are and hence often the
last to seek political change. The most
effective people in political activity
are running from the lower middle
class through the upper-middle class.
They are the people who are literate, who write
the news, who envy the very rich, and who seek
political change. And what kind of policies
do they want? Welfare programs for themselves.
One famous policy that runs throughout
almost all democratic societies is
state-financed higher education. It is
sold on the grounds of providing equal
opportunities to everybody to get an
education. But what are the facts? Who
is really benefiting? Who are the people
who are attending public universities?
It’s usually people who come from the middle,
and upper-class families. Occasionally
there is someone from a lower-class
family, but that’s a small fraction
Children from middle and
upper-income families often
attend public education for the longest periods,
gaining new skills and building strong networks
that enable them to get higher-paying jobs.
The taxpayers pay for it, including parents
from the bottom of the income distribution whose
children are unlikely to attend college and in
the rare instance that they do so, often drop out.
Friedmann called state-financed
higher education a program to
impose taxes on the people in Watts to send
the children from Beverly Hills to college.
What are your thoughts? Was Friedmann right? And
if so, what’s a good alternative to help create
equal opportunities in a democracy?
Share your thoughts in the comments
below and read the description for more
information about Friedmann and our work.
One learning platform we really like,
because it allows you to practice what we
preach— learning by doing — is Brilliant.org.
Brilliant has thousands of lessons ranging from
everyday math to scientific
thinking and data science.
To learn data science for example,
you select the level of math you are
comfortable with and start with
your first lesson on probability.
You’ll learn to calculate the odds of making
a sale given a specific set of conditions
or calculate the chance that a particular
group had seen the same two films.
To try this lesson and everything else
Brilliant has to offer — free — for a
full 30 days, visit brilliant.org/sprouts
or click on the link in the description.
The first 200 of you will get 20% off
Brilliant's annual premium subscription.
Brought to you with the support of brilliant.org/
To learn more check one of our other videos.
To support our work and change education,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts. Or
read more about us in the description.